with all the rewrites test screenings
and last-minute edits it's amazing that
any film gets made at all but every so
often everything lines up just perfectly
bring together the right screenplay with
the right director cast and crew and you
just might get a perfect film these
movies are few and far between but when
they come along you know right away that
you found a flawless film Mulholland
Drive explaining the plot of maja land
drive is like trying to describe a deep
and disturbing dream it leaves you
emotional and Confused in equal measure
director David Lynch uses the film to
explore the darker aspects of Hollywood
and how often our grand goals give way
to despair while you're sifting through
all this dream logic Lynch keeps you
glued to the screen with mesmerizing
sequences like Naomi Watts Betty turning
standard movie audition dialogue into
something genuinely chilling you're
playing a dangerous game here if you're
trying to blackmail me it's no wonder
that in 2016 the BBC named this
surrealist masterpiece the greatest film
of the 21st century in a pod the
orchestra
[Music]
Manchester by the sea written and
directed by Kenneth Lonergan Manchester
by the sea tells the story of Lee
Chandler an irritable janitor forced to
return to his hometown to look after his
nephew following the loss of his brother
we don't want to give away too much of
the plot there's a reason that going
home is the last thing Lee wants to do
every sight and sound reminds him of
something truly tragic that happened
years ago and events so horrible he
might never recover Casey Affleck won an
Oscar for his performances Lee as did
Lonergan for Best Original Screenplay
and the two truly deserved their
accolades every gesture Affleck makes
every line he doesn't say aches would
pain and while the film is full of
uncomfortably comic moments Manchester
by the sea grapples with grief in a way
that most movies wouldn't dare it's a
beautifully brutal film about living
with pain forever the which one of the
most disturbing horror movies in recent
memory the which tells the story of a
Puritan family fighting for their lives
when a supernatural force attacks their
isolated farmhouse director Robert
Eggers spent four years studying the
Puritan lifestyle and reading first-hand
accounts of demonic possession in order
to write the script as accurately as
possible he also got super involved when
it came to sets and props the costumes
were hand-sewn and the furniture was
built just like the Puritans used to do
it Edgar's wanted everything perfect and
it certainly shows in the actual movie
by paying so much attention to the
little details in every scene the film
fully immerses viewers in the
nightmarish setting even besides all the
props and research Eggers managed to get
incredible performances from the child
actors and somehow found the scariest
goat to ever put on film and if a movie
can make
livestock scary you know you've got an
instant horror classic on your hands the
grand Budapest hotel in retrospect it
seems like Wes Anderson's entire career
was building up to the grand Budapest
hotel it's the perfect blend of all
things Anderson from his meticulous
world building and witty dialogue to the
melancholy air that hovers over all of
his films
plot involves a lobby boy named Zira
played by Tony Revit Lori who comes to
work for the flamboyant and foul-mouthed
muncher Gustave at the grand Budapest
hotel
as with most Anderson movies a plot
summary doesn't capture the unique wit
and unmistakable cinematography that
makes grand Budapest so appealing
walthaus zero confused zero confused
indeed the plot thickens as they say why
by the way is it a soup metaphor with a
brilliant lead performance from rape
vines as who stopped the grand budapest
hotel is a fanciful breath of fresh air
it's proof that style and substance can
go hand in hand
Creed Ryan Coogler Creed isn't just a
great rocky sequel it's a great movie
all on its own Michael B Jordan puts in
a jaw-dropping performance as Adonis
Creed the son of the late great champ
Apollo Creed Adonis is eager to fight
and desperate to prove himself and he
turns to the legendary Rocky Balboa for
help as Adonis boxes his way to a title
shot director Ryan Coogler builds on the
franchise mythology in exciting ways and
then there's the moment when Adonis goes
to battle the champ and the famous rocky
theme starts playing in the greatest
nostalgia fueled moment of the last 20
years Jordan is on his a game here
giving us a hero who's not a Rocky
Balboa clone but a young man with his
own issues and dreams Creed was an
underdog movie that defied everyone's
expectations and it can hold its own as
one of the greatest sequels of all time
silence in 1988 Martin Scorsese took a
new look at the Gospels with The Last
Temptation of Christ and nearly 30 years
later score says he returned to religion
with silence a movie about a man's
crisis of faith when it seems he's been
forsaken by God the plot involves two
Jesuit priests played by Andrew Garfield
and Adam driver who sneaked into Japan
to find a missing mentor who has
supposedly abandon his faith when
Garfield's priest is captured he finds
himself confronted with a difficult
decision recant his faith and risk
damnation or watch as his fellow
Christians are tortured to death
think about the suffering you have
inflicted on these P
just because I'll be a selfish dream of
a Christian Japan silence is beautifully
shot by Rodrigo Prieto who contrasts the
beauty of Japan with the brutality of
crucified men drowning in the sea
ultimately silence explores the nature
of faith how it can inspire both hope
and cruelty and how it can rip apart
lives and give others the strength to
soldier on get out as Jordan Peele
famously said on The Late Show get out
as a documentary you've submitted this
for them to the Golden Globes as a
comedy I submitted as a documentary it's
a fictional version of the horrors black
people experience every day in America
the story follows a young black
photographer named Chris played
wonderfully by Daniel Kaluga who goes to
meet his white girlfriend's family from
the moment he shows up at their estate
everything seems off and it's hard to
tell if it's casual racism or something
more overtly sinister this is feels
directorial debut but he shows himself
to be a master at drawing out the
tension until everything explodes in a
bloody mess of jujitsu teacups and deer
antlers
although Pele is best known for his
comedic work on key and Peele get out
shows that he's even better at
terrifying an audience than he was in
making people laugh
Eternal Sunshine of the spotless mind
michel gondry is a director known for
his whimsical imagination Charlie
Kaufman is a screenwriter known for his
witty pessimism when the two combined
their cinematic powers for Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind
they created an all-time great romance
that took a long hard look at the ugly
side of love and how relationships
actually work I've been thinking lately
how I was before and how I am now and
it's like he changed me I feel like I'm
always pissy now I don't like myself
when I'm with him I don't like myself
anymore
this inventive romance skipped through
time and memories as Jim Carrey's Joel
re-experience 'as the memories of his
failed relationship the film doesn't
ignore the pain and pitfalls of making a
relationship work and by examining the
different stages of romance this is a
movie that changes and grows with each
and every viewing this is it
it's gonna be gone soon
[Music]